Tom Cruise's next film is a very
adventurous very original sci-fi
adventure which he will play a man who
travels back in time to confront the
younger version of himself you [ __ ]
kidding me
it's tentatively called our name is Adam
hmm sounds super we're rather looper or
Gooper not the Tom Cruise gay I'd like
to see that [ __ ] movie man a movie
where it's just like they send you back
in time to come in your own face if you
could go back in time I would totally
come in my own face Oh an RB just to
[ __ ] with me man just to give me [ __ ] to
talk about with my friends like some fat
stranger in a hockey jersey broke into
my room and game in my face
[Applause]
one day you're gonna understand this
little boy but seriously if if you had
any sort of by curiosity whatsoever yes
that'd be the way to do it right go back
and suck yourself off yeah okay cuz it's
not really gay if it's you know it's
like a fighter cough it's not like I'm
jerking some other dude up it's not
really gay cuz it's me straight up it's
the past it's a gay pass right so if I
show up and I want to [ __ ] around with
myself I'm good right absolutely man you
take it straight in the mouth up the ass
and [ __ ] armpit and you can let
people watch man your parents could be
there anyways all that could happen and
even Jesus himself could be standing by
and he would say it's not gates himself
you lost me at armpit
[Music]
you
[Music]